Film Courage: Bing, was there a day that filmmaking
mattered to you more than skateboarding?
Bing Liu, filmmaker of MINDING THE GAP: There
were some days that it did and some days that
it didn’t.
So when I was 17 I watched the film SLACKER
and I took the freaks and geeks of my community
in Rockford [Illinois] and I sort of had them
improv them talking about their lives, bumping
into each other, it was very Slackeresque.
On that day filmmaking mattered more to me
than skateboarding and then I kept making
skate videos and my next film that I did I
cared more about filmmaking, I don’t know
if I’m answering my question or not?
Film Courage: You are.
I mean whenever you take on a project whether
it’s having a Youtube channel or doing a
documentary, it takes over your life in so
many ways, like you basically have no free
time, like this is pretty much what you’re
doing for a good chunk of time.
Was there a point where you said “If I’m
going to put skateboarding on the back burner
and to me making this film is everything and
I need to do it for me.”
Bing: I mean skateboarding…I feel like it
was never that choice, there was never that
fork in the road.
I was 24 when I started doing this film.
I really wanted to explore these themes of
family and violence and childhood so I went
around the country and interviewed skateboarders
from all over the place.
It confirmed my belief that there are a lot
of patterns in the community.
And then a year in I met Keire [one of the
three stories in MINDING THE GAP] and I was
like “Oh, this person hasn’t processed
it in the ways that other people have.”
Later in the documentary Zack [one of the
three stories in MINDING THE GAP] is like
“Yeah of course my father beat me.”
I feel like most people brushed it off like
that.
There is something that had hardened over
the softness that Keire still held onto.
And that’s why I saw myself in Keire.
Keire is willing to do the work of processing
it, to not just brush it off, to make it something
that mattered to him and that he wanted to
change.
Film Courage: Absolutely, he was incredibly
open and I really appreciate that.
Speaking of which (and Zack), I think there
was one scene early on in the film where Zack
kind of looked at you (he might have been
smoking or doing something) and he said “Are
you going to film this?”
And then he says “You know what, you can
pretty much film whatever you want.”
How do you earn that level of trust with someone,
even a friend because this thing [gestures
to the camera] can shape someone in any way
they want it to in the editing room?
How do you earn that level of trust?
Bing: I think it was just a five year long
conversation about representation.
That was one of many moments both on and off
camera where we talked about what was going
to go in the film, how they felt about what
we had captured so far.
And sometimes they were light and funny like
that smoking moment.
But other times it was like “Zack how do
you feel about me having film you run off
to Denver?
How do you feel about you sort of abandoning
your son?”
You know so they understood that I was checking
in, that I cared.
And I told them a couple of years before we
finished the film that they were going to
get a chance to see the film before it was
picture locked and weigh in.
Film Courage: I’m wondering when you actually
started filming in general whether they were
skateboarding videos or whatever?
When was the first time you picked up a camera?
Bing: 14 maybe?
Film Courage: So pre-DSLR I guess?
Bing: Pre-DSLR.
I mean mini-DV tape was the height of technology
at the time and then soon after recording
to DVD came and then recording to hard drive
cameras.
Film Courage: I believe initially you were
not intending to put yourself in the film.
And I can see why, I know a lot of people
have their own take on that.
It definitely works, it absolutely works that
you’re in the film.
I think you said that at some point your editor
and you sat down and you edited all three
stories separately to see if they worked?
Can you talk about how that worked?
Bing: I met Josh [Altman] last year editing
a different project and I convinced him to
come on to consult at first because he didn’t
have time to edit fully and he told me you
should try editing every story on its own
to get it working and so I did that and on
the first try with Keire and Zack stories
it was like “Okay, we have a film here for
sure that can get into Sundance.”
And I was like “What?”
Because that was the first time someone had
told me that.
And then for my story it was like “We’re
not sure how this is going to work?
We’ll figure it out later.
So we wove Zack and Keire’s stories together.
You know ultimately it was finding, it was
sort of characterizing the camera as the character
to ultimately lead up to the mom interview.
Film Courage: How was that to know that the
film could go to Sundance and beyond?
I mean most people hope for that and they
don’t actually get it.
But then you’re filming this incredibly
personal story (for all parties involved)
to know that “Oh my gosh, this is happening?”
Bing: Because I wasn’t doing it for Sundance.
I mean there was a large part of me that wasn’t
doing it just to make a film.
It was so important to me that I would have
just wanted to do it.
The goal is to get it seen very widely so
it can make a difference, I mean Sundance
was great for that purpose.
But I’m very much a realist and I’m just
like and I very much live in the moment.
I mean I’m still just sort of waiting to
wake up and “Oh?
None of that happened.”
Of course, the last nine months was just a
dream.
Film Courage: I think you had said in a Q&A
or maybe it was someone else that what is
effective about MINDING THE GAP is also what
is not being said.
Is there anything you want to talk about that
in terms of some of the things you just show
and some of the things you leave out and the
audience can kind of fill in the gaps (and
no pun intended) in terms of what is happening
or some of the emptiness around some of the
lives of the skateboarders?
Bing: I think that first year those interviews
were really on the nose.
And that first assembly cut was very much
just people really directly talking about
abuse and violence.
It was just you know really hard to watch
and for many reasons.
And once it became more about a story of Zack
and Keire growing up and these issues of abuse
and trauma coming out organically as obstacles
to their growing up I think it became a lot
more emotionally grappling.
A little does a lot and I think ultimately
that was how we were able to fit so many themes
that are in the film, race, class, gender
relations, masculinity.
If you really just look at the mechanics of
this story, there is really just a one-two-punch
for some of these themes.
Like for race (for example) there are really
three moments that deal with race in the film
but it says everything you need to know about
how this affects Keire.
Film Courage: Can you talk about the types
of filming where you want the subjects to
pretend that the camera was not there and
then filming where you do want the subjects
to look straight at the camera?
How did you balance that or was this not even
conscious?
It was just you were filming?
Bing: I wasn’t really conscious, I mean
I certainly adhered to vérité (the school
of vérité) which is that you just hang out
and something happens and you start filming.
For me I feel like I watched a lot of vérité
films that showed how the camera effected
the story and the presence of the camera and
there is something actually more truthful
to that.
So I think that’s why we left in moments
like Zack asking me like “Do you want me
to pretend like the camera is not there or
what?”
Because it just sort of nods to the fact that
yeah we’re both constructing it and we’re
filming things and the camera might affect
how they’re acting but you can’t always
do that (it would be exhausting), so there’s
more truth to that.
Film Courage: We asked some of our viewers
questions ahead of time.
We just let them know that it was a documentary
but we didn’t tell them too much but they
wanted to know, the first viewer asked (his
name is ZombieDude64)…
Bing: I love this, this is awesome.
Film Courage: And I’m assuming it’s a
he, I haven’t looked at his account “So
what are your tips on finding screenings for
the film?”
Bing: Finding screenings?
Like feedback screenings?
Film Courage: Yeah, how did you arrange screenings
or was it all festival submissions and that’s
how?
Bing: Oh, I see.
Well I mean getting into Sundance positions
you really well for festivals to come to you.
A friend of mine Stephen Elliott he’s a
filmmaker who did this journalistic piece
about film fest fees - you should Google it,
I mean it’s really telling about sort of
the behind-the-curtains look of how some of
the films get accepted into festivals and
the whole micro-economy behind that.
And there is unfairness there but I think
it speaks to being a filmmaker who is independent
making their first film and having two learn
how to play the game while also learning the
rules of the game at the same time and it
can be really frustrating.
But I think these things always change.
I don’t know I mean maybe the next film
I make will be distributed in a different
way, I’ll have to apply more but for the
most part we got into Sundance, won an award
and basically every fest we got into has asked
for our film.
And it’s not like automatic either, a lot
of festivals still reject us.
It’s just that they want to come to us and
ask us for a screener.
Film Courage: At what point did the film become
a movie about fathers?
I think you said you set out to just film
people about family?
Bing: It was set out to be like that.
I asked every skateboarder about that.
It was sort of built in thematically at the
beginning.
All the themes are built in thematically it’s
just the way that the themes were told shifted
over time.
Film Courage: I don’t know if I’ll keep
this part in.
I know the interviewer is not supposed to
reveal too much but having grown up without
a father (I had like one phone conversation
with him, that was it), I noticed looking
back on my life that every friend I had, they
had a missing parent and then I had this connection
with them and I didn’t even realize that
consciously [until later].
Is that something may you saw with the film
that a lot of the people who bonded were able
to bond in a way that was…there was stuff
that was not said but maybe because they’d
had a missing so to speak?
Bing: Yeah, I think heartache really finds
affinity with heartache, I certainly felt
that way.
I was friends with people who knew some deep
level of pain and I enjoyed being around them
because it made me feel less alone in my situation.
Otherwise when I think I was hanging around
people who were more white bread or vanilla
with their situations at home, it did make
me feel a little less than and made me feel
bad about myself even though it wasn’t my
own fault.
You know, when you’re a kid you can’t
help that.
So hanging out with people that shared my
pain ultimately it was like an ad-hoc family
all of its own.
Film Courage: I used to dread going to friends’
houses that would have the big family dinners
because I wasn’t used to that and it was
so foreign to me and to know like “Okay,
well you have to wait for so and so to speak
first.”
These unwritten rules.
Bing: It’s super weird and what it does
though it sort of enlightens you to the constructedness
of these things and ultimately to everything
and maybe this is a system of this because
I went to school for English and it was more
like theory and criticism but my big takeaway
is like everything is constructed and we can
deconstruct everything and so I don’t know
I feel like I was primed for that in the situations
growing up where I just felt like I was coat
switching, I felt like an outsider in that
I was performing to fit in.
Film Courage: How many years were you making
the film?
When did you begin and when was the final
edit?
Bing: I was about 24 when I began filming.
I was editing all along the way in my bedroom.
We got funding late 2016 and then we started
our search for an editor.
By that point I had a pretty decent rough
cut.
I was like if we’re going to be paying someone
$2,500.00 a week, they better be good.
But the problem is in documentary at least
the really good editors are booked like a
year or two in advance.
I was really lucky I met Josh working on another
project.
He looked at the rough cut and he agreed to
come on to consult and then he had a few months
free to jump in with me.
So that was sort of the big picture process
of crafting the film.
It wasn’t until the last few months that
I dug into archival footage and built up the
sense of this is just a skate video that turned
into something else.
And even with Keire I didn’t know him growing
up.
I accidentally filmed a clip of him fighting.
I had to source of a lot of his footage from
other people that were more his age because
he’s 7 or 8 years younger than me.
Zack I had more footage of because we actually
were closer in age.
Film Courage: We had another viewer write
in.
Bing: What’s the viewer’s name?
Film Courage: His name is John Dimelu (and
I’m sorry John if I’m saying your name
incorrectly).
So he asks “How do you know when you really
have a story to tell?
And why do you choose to tell it?”
So at what point did you know, okay this is
taking shape?
This is more than just interviews about family
and why did you go ahead to take the final
leap and find an editor that costs $2,500
a week?
Bing: I think I was ready to take the plunge
when I did the fellowship with Kartemquin
[Kartemquin Films, based in Chicago, Illinois]
and watched a lot of vérité films and just
trusted the process of these characters lives
are going to lead…I mean it’s all about
casting, too.
I saw in Keire this opportunity to capture
his internal transformation and processing
both with his father and race and growing
up.
For Zack it was pretty clear that he was going
to have some issues with becoming a young
father.
Like he wasn’t quite ready for it.
Our second shoot we did together with Zack
I went into the hospital.
Nina [another young woman featured in the
film] was getting induced for labor because
she was late.
They botched her epidurals, she flatlined
it was very traumatic for her.
We did a long interview with her afterwards.
I mean that was the beginning of it.
It was like "Okay, this is going to be a film.”
Film Courage: Did you tell your subjects (and
I know they were really more like friends)
that whatever you filmed would end up in the
movie?
Or did you allow them…I know you said at
the beginning [of our interview] that everybody
got to see it before it was finally released.
But was that something along the way where
you said “If you don’t like it, I’ll
take it out.”
Or “everything I film is going to end up
here?”
Bing: It was a five year conversation about
what was going to be in the film or not.
And there was never once where they were like
“Don’t put this in the film.”
Except for when we were dealing with Nina
and what she wanted in the film in terms of
her relationship with Zack and the abuse.
And that was out of a desire to make the relationship
work.
And in my head I was like “Well, she could
change her mind.”
This relationship was really fickle and ultimately
if she sees the final cut and doesn’t want
this aspect of the film in, we’ve got to
respect her wishes.
I mean there is a famous story about Kirsten
Johnson who did CAMERAPERSON.
She worked on a film for two years following
these Afghani women and at the end of the
process she showed the the film and one of
them didn’t want to be in the film at all.
And so it was like two or three years of work…not
down the drain but that she ethically had
to put aside and that ultimately made her
think about why…”What am I doing documenting
these lives?”
And that led to CAMERAPERSON.
Film Courage: Yeah, it’s a really fine line
because you have to at some point, put your
foot down and say “This is my project.”
But then it’s also someone’s life and
someone’s legacy.
People still have to go about their lives
and people will recognize them from the film.
Bing: I mean there’s a power dynamic at
work that is so different from journalism.
You know, journalism you go in, you get some
interview bites and then you leave.
We’re asking for years worth of vulnerability
and representation from these people and it
would be one thing if this film were about
Anthony.
He has a lot more power than Nina does.
Nina especially in this group is the most
vulnerable.
She doesn’t have the communal and friend
support that Keire and Zack have and she’s
a woman.
Everything is sort of stacked against her
in this situation.
So especially her I had to listen to and I
lost sleep thinking “What if she doesn’t
want this to happen?”
But ultimately everyone watched the film and
they were like “You got it.
You captured it.”
Film Courage: Now the film [MINDING THE GAP]
is going to be released August 17th?
Bing: It releases August 17th on Hulu.
It will be in theaters, several across the
country and then a broadcast on POV [Point
Of View on PBS] in 2019.
Film Courage: How does this feel?
That’s going to change things…a lot in
so many ways in terms of the reach, people
knowing everybody’s story.
How does that feel?
Bing: I don’t know.
I think I’m like disassociating right now.
I mean that’s a coping mechanism I learned
when I was growing up.
But I think the way I handle stress is I recognize
what I can and can’t control and I’ve
literally no control over what the film is
going to do.
I’m eager to see what it’s going to do.
I’m not sure I feel much yet.
I think probably 11:59 on August 16th I’m
going to feel nervousness but right now I’m
just like “What’s for dinner?”
Film Courage: You can Tweet about it.
That’s the new coping mechanism.
Bing: Exactly.
Film Courage: Well I’m sure that people
who have been in a similar situation are going
to definitely resonate with the film.
And maybe it will bring up some old stuff
but I think…just…seeing it I was still
thinking about it the next morning and I’m
watching people who are a total different
generation than myself but seeing them go
through the exact same things that I went
through.
So I think that for a lot of people it may
be healing in some way.
It may bring up some old stuff but I think
it’s really important for people to watch
this movie.
Bing: Something that…when we showed Nina
the fine cut she relived the relationship
with Zack.
They’d been split up for over a year at
that point but she fell back in love with
him, his charisma and she was also hurt by
him again.
We had to process that with her afterwards
and her feelings.
There was one screening that was at a college
in the spring that she came out to and there
was a domestic violence shelter there with
a booth that also drew out some people from
their community and there were these women
who were twice her age who were saying “Your
relationship with Zack reminds me of my relationship
with my husband.
You were so brave for getting out now.
You’re so brave for telling your story.”
I could just see it where all of these women
were just pouring their hearts out to her
that Nina was realizing that her story was
bigger than her own.
I mean I have dozens of stories like that
where there’s just been these really personal
effects in people that is going to translate
I think to them being a different father,
them being a different person emotionally.
It’s been pretty amazing so far and I hope
it continues to have that impact.
Film Courage: We had another question that
came in, it’s much more light-hearted.
Bing: What’s the user name?
Film Courage: His name is Nafis Mustafa.
Bing: Okay.
I’m just hoping for another ZombieDude64
or something?
Film Courage: And Nafis, he has commented
before.
He’s been great.
And he writes “What would your advice be
to aspiring filmmakers?”
Let’s suppose someone is 14 again but this
time instead of mini-DV they have 4k, this
amazing camera and they don’t know what
to do with it?
Bing: Do it for the love.
When I was growing up in Rockford, being a
filmmaker was just such a realistic thing.
I was just doing it for the love.
I was emulating things.
It felt good to be creative but in terms of
making a film you know these things take years.
So don’t pick something that you’re not
truly passionate about, pick something that
you care about more than just making a film
about.
And I think everyone because of their personal
experience, because of where they come from,
because they way they think, everyone has
at least one story within themselves that
only they can tell and nobody else can tell
and I think people should honor and respect
that for themselves.
And I don’t just mean making a personal
film about themselves.
It’s just that we really need to sort of
have understanding across many different aisles
and lines that seem a little bit more too
highlighted these days lines of division.
Film Courage: What did you use to film the
movie, from the mini-DV to…I mean there
were definitely shots in the film that were
not mini-DV.
Bing: I consider all that stuff archival.
So I filmed it with three different DSLRs
and (Canon) C300.
Film Courage: Did you outline the documentary
or did you have any kind of story structure
to it?
Bing: Yes, it started out in probably…I’ve
done like 40 grant applications in those years
and got rejected for 39 of them…38 of them.
But grant applications ask for either a treatment
or a synopsis or something right.
And then as I got deeper into editing I put
scenes on Post-it notes (I put them on the
wall).
I kept a very detailed log while I was shooting
and that comes from me working in the camera
department for money to pay rent.
And then in the final year I moved to an online
whiteboard that Josh Altman turned me onto
called RealTimeBoard.
It’s a lot easier than writing on Post-it
notes and sticky notes get unsticky and they
fall.
It’s all digital and it’s online and you
can share between different users and you
can instantly duplicate a whole thing and
then rearrange stuff.
So there are several different versions of
both written treatments and scene outlines.
Film Courage: In the end, what do you want
people to gain from the film?
I mean there are so many themes to this films
and so many takeaways.
It’s about family, fatherhood, breaking
out of a little town or deciding to stay.
What do you want people to gain from MINDING
THE GAP?
Bing: Life moves really fast.
We go into our 20’s and we get a job, a
career, family (maybe).
Then we turn 30 and all of the sudden we get
old.
But then we’ve often experienced adolescence
as a time where our emotions are not taken
seriously.They are brushed off as like just
grow up or oh, you’re being so emotional.
And there are all these epithets that sort
of unconsciously tell us like oh no, we need
to grow up, we need to grow up.
But in fact that time of adolescence it’s
such a soft time, such a malleable time and
it just informs who we become so much.
Even in the little things like getting our
first job or taking about our father for the
first time with a trusted friend, that stuff
really matters.
And I think we should give it the respect
and the analysis that it deserves.
I think it will help us understand ourselves
as adults.
Also, we were talking about this off camera
but there are millions of Zack and Keire’s
out there and not all of them happen to skateboard.
These are issues that youth face across the
board.
Film Courage: Yeah and I think what is interesting
too is it affects you even beyond thirty and
that’s something that people don’t realize,
whether you are a parent or not.
Bing: You can brush it off, you can sweep
it underneath the rug but I mean those seeds
that are planted are going to grow.